let me need to clear this mixer
Evan hopefully that looks okay okay
I mean site okay I'm playing a below
something a below FA's good luck sweetie
for
Ches I missed Gotham chess I was just
talking about Gotham chess Gotham chess
if you're still here
I just made another Kasparov e-notes
we'll have competing emotes
yeah okay tournament is started I
haven't posted a turn in a long time
let's play Queen f3 here
this is song this is supposed to be
slightly better for lights
quicker developments d4 is coming
Nathan's at work
isn't that where you're supposed to play
chess just at work
at least you're in the chat that's nice
g3 or d4 it's by g3 I might want a
Castle queenside at some point I'm gonna
keep my options open
yeah I did hit actually I like yesterday
I had 1,100 subscribers but Thank You
Nathan
I was gonna have like some celebratory
tweet and like social media posts but
I'm holding off let's play Bishop III
here
I'm about to hit a thousand subscribers
on Twitter I need like two or three more
and then maybe I'll make some
celebratory posts so I eleven hundred
subs on YouTube YouTube subs are free so
I don't get I don't get money like
twitch but it's still it's still nice
because now at least on YouTube I can
not monetize the channel and hopefully
be more motivated to put outs more
interesting content
which I've already started doing I
started like I'm chopping up twitch
streams my queen is really awkward let's
play 94 make sure he doesn't have too
many of media tactics
you
let's do this
I just play the worst move ever
was the most recent video yeah cuz my
previous videos were just like stream
archives I would just call them like
beating players at chess or something
but what I realize is I can just cut a
video have it like one game I'm not
losing a pawn like Bishop h4 yeah I just
have like a shorter video with one game
and have a clearer title
so I've already like done that for like
this class the classical tournament that
was a few days ago I took most of the
games that I played and made made them
as their own YouTube videos so anyway
let's focus on not losing I want to play
e5
I had to get out of this pin first now
e5 looks enticing
maybe he has to play he fight himself
who knows
titles attract more viewers yeah at some
point I want to make custom thumbnails
too but I'm not at this stage that not
at that stage yet but maybe someday does
he have to play g5 that's gonna be such
a sad move for him if he does its take
the bishop first
trying to figure out what to do against
g5g five I take the night he takes back
maybe I just play Bishop take g5
g5s really the only try for him did not
just be down a piece
I only have 29 subscribers on on Twitch
as impressive as YouTube okay I'm gonna
take I think this is working as
calculating if rook GA Queen h4
and I keep the pin which is really
important
and here I just assumed I can play queen
H something and say Queen h6 and then
like rookie 4 and made him or her
if I take take rookie three is that
effective
hey Annika just subscribed gifted by
Nathan Wow
nathan is such a class act thanks for
the 30 bits 2 for 30 subs
I was looking at my like my analytics
and Nathan is my second biggest cheer of
all time
right behind koi TV so Thank You Nathan
for the generosity
yeah rook g3 it's hard to stop
just might be force mates
of course mate because if he plays some
F on moves still rock g3 king of seven
queen g6 mate
pretty sure it's worse mates
that's nice I am going for a run I have
it in my calendar today is a busy stream
day I'm doing three separate streams
today but I scheduled them in advance
I've also updated my my schedule on my
websites so I'll be putting the streams
hopefully more in advance okay I'm on
the kid is tied for first
and cool-guy is tied for first man cool
guy I want to play cool guy next he's
already played three games that's
awesome if anyone's watching this and
you're not in the tournament you can
join the tournament I'll share the link
again soon let's Blizzard sky let's play
four
let me just share the link and let's
play a close to ceiling
cool guy your lead is not going to last
hopefully but we'll see if you keep
playing more games in it then everyone
might be a good strategy ePHI what is e
5
se5 playable it just seems to give light
more opportunities usually black plays
east six in such structures yeah I
understand that this time control might
be too fast for people I just didn't
want to do like a 10-minute tournament
and then only be able to play like a
handful of games
I didn't want like a long term in either
so if people want a slower time control
I'll take that into account for next
time
if
tournament over the weekend I'm okay
yeah I'm I'm open to extreme suggestions
if people want to see like a specific
type of stream I know there's a lot of
requests for classical chess or slower
slower instructive streams so I want to
do like a Q&A stream or like some
opening opening educational stream I
don't know figure it out
should I play f5 here f59 h5 let's tee
I should focus on this cos time is
running low Queen h4 is coming expecting
Knight h5 Queen h4 g6 and maybe I'll
maneuver let's play h4 actually hey a
Belgian novice 250 bits do more
classical chess okay just for a Belgian
novice my goal is to schedule one
classical stream for this week at least
one should say it steak I want to open
up lines
Bishop g5 was a bad move
I was a terrible mouth
I shoulda played Bishop h6
I'm worse here
do I do Queeny no I'm much worse here
this is bad
you
I could very potentially lose to this
guy
but I'm gonna fight the problem with the
zhurqis I have no increments kind of
forgot about that i threatening ortega
for it might be
a heap to fans
I'm bring my pieces closer
you
this is a terrifying position maybe a
rook g3 is coming
yeah because we're both trying to attack
on the same side I have no time
I'll go for 94 ideas
but he's 1,600
oh no oh this is so bad I'm losing to a
1600 in my own tournament
this is really really bad
mm this is rated to know
can I trick him maybe I'll trick him
all it takes is one now slip
please keep thinking
move your knight somewhere
I still have some old weight he moved
his night what what does this move he
just he gave me everything in one move
thank you
give me g6
that turned around quickly still have to
watch my time though
what do I do
but I have to watch my time this is not
an easy position to convert with eight
seconds left
ah he hung his rook
you
he's thinking okay take that
three seconds left
you
time to start pre moving
hey I made it him I did not deserve to
win that at all but I want it that was
it
I'm sorry guy um well what was this
night move um I've only played 2 means
already
what was this night move ah
he thought he was pinning this Bishop
and he's attacking twice but he forgot
my rook is also attacking the Queen is
yeah I attacked the canoe from two
directions okay well he was nervous
probably or something back to
tournaments ah I was intense
okay I'm behind on a kid who is won all
his games and I passed cool guy who
still has four points
you
I'm controlled vote hey thanks for
sharing it to a poll I've wanted to do
more like feedback polls they're just
hard to organize but I actually do
appreciate this
um I'm not gonna vote in the poll is
it's gonna be determined by what people
want let's do another berserk and let's
not not give any mercy of this game
we're gonna see a London
no no London I'm kind of Kali play g6
whoa what is this move it's taken then
g6
you
[Music]
interesting
maybe six
get away with this Queen b3 is sometimes
scary but any six
I just want a castle and play positional
chess okay this is nice now because I'll
play Bishop g4
and this pawn is a long-term target this
is very nice there's so much pressure
from all directions
is going to play like Bishop III
I'm player ft8
a plan is to okay when the
right I want it windy for but there's
really no rush pretty sure I can win it
anytime I want I might slow play like
restrict the night with b6 and then
double up
and you just wait for him to give me
something but now maybe I have to take
okay now we'll just play positional
chess take everything be up upon with
better pawn structure
one minute to convert this
you
yeah this is much more controlled than
the previous game
I'm playing more games like this
you
yeah I'm pretty sure he gave me the
bishop pair cuz sometimes a tendency
when a low-rated player is playing a
much higher rate player the tendency is
to trade and it's one of the most common
mistakes I see when playing low rate
players they'll be too eager to trade
and then they make trades which just
benefit benefit me which I'm happy with
by g5
go for the pond storm
this is a classic example of active
versus passive rook
I still need to prove
gonna win this
that was a bad decision by me
now I'm giving them counterplay I still
want to play e4
yeah so he's gonna play one of these
removes and I'll play e4
okay I'm still happy
you
I pre move our TIG of three
[Music]
if you plays kingi - I'll take the pond
let's do this
I don't think he can defend this fun
as you can counter-attack
this rook this rook has no squares now
he's going to play like h4 and I'll play
King g6
wait this is actually a bit tricky to
win because we're trading a lot of pawns
I was about to play King f5 and blunder
everything
illustrate rooks okay now it's winning
there's not the smoothest conversion
those rook got some activity
wait a minute am I not oh whoa I'm
winning this okay if I took the pot I
think it would have been a draw taketake
no I would have had opposition okay
I should know that
if this were chess calm I would have
three moves all the way to queening what
guidelines do you have on trades make
trades that benefit you if you're not
sure then don't trade hey I'm playing a
raccoon aah berserk yeah let's beserk
I'll play a London
this guy was the first guy to to be in
this chat
one of the first to join the tournament
I miss III III III also worked okay I
have to move quicker Bishop d6 this is a
fun line and then queen g4 I played
Vallejo in like one minute I beat him in
like 10 moves in this line that was
great
he plundered some some I don't know
childish thing Queen f8 Vallejo played
Queen FA - and then I went for this sort
of attack
it's a pawn now I think after like the
level played c5 and the knight b5 it's
almost already winning
and this might already be working too
I guess he has Queen before check muddy
of the waters okay let's go for the kill
I think I'm winning immediately here
it's very pleasant I want to do this and
then this and then this
stuff to bring more pieces to the tech
that's a good move but it shouldn't do
anything
it's gonna get some counterplay
whereas my win play rook t1 first
you
wait can he castle here he hasn't moved
his oh he has moved his king okay
got scared for a moment if he could
castle that would be a very good move
King f8
okay
what to do
much time to think
to this
wait a minute am i mating is this this
is force mate right queen g6
that's good I didn't dream of this spawn
capture it was now this if you had if
you play King yet I would have 97
minutes
as nice they missed something else 9 of
695 was Nathan saying
Wendy eighths
yeah Queen D 898
six I was scared that I have 92
'we know and then he plays - six I don't
think that line works
wait berserk do I just play berserk or
he's just saying he's a raccoon
wait what just happened there wait I
lost a game cuz I forgot
no wait how did that happen I didn't
even see the game starts oh that's
actually him okay I believe you
sad why
I know how that started I was just
analyzing the game maybe I went back to
the tournament and I got confused close
my tabs
I'll have to watch the replay of it I
have no idea how that happened
my books rating and
streak I still have first place so
that's what counts
that guy's probably like having the day
of his life right now
probably had another tab open that's
probably like it probably started
another tab I just didn't see it I was
so enthralled with this line that Nathan
shared it's all Nathan's faults close
all my tabs ok bombas I won't desert get
back on a streak
play some qgd who some what is this play
a 5 a 4
before
okay looks weird Nathan F with a hundred
bits saying he's sorry I kind of accept
the apology it still stings
we're going to figure out the structure
the dough is kind of a weird structure I
play like b5 or a c5 some day maybe six
at b6 Bishop d7 over this setup
you just wanna pond
initiative
this queen is tied down to this night's
so he has to move here or here
he moves here I wish of t3u moves here
okay let's play Bishop t3
I am down the pond but I'm trying to be
annoying
Nathan with the clip
happiest clip
know how to keep the initiative here
just running a steam
maybe see five make a threat he's going
to take and I probably take with pawn
positions like this search two
strategies either to continue making
threats or to just try and clamp down
the opponent and not give them any
active play but I need to improve my
pieces
it's just improve if you plays here
maybe I'll play this and someone just
followed thank you who or whoever
followed ninety five is a decent move
but I can attack it curious zero seven
thanks for the follow it's about to say
double-oh-seven is only one zero
count yeah maybe I'll hit $2,000 by the
end of this month that would be exciting
I was watching just chill extreme oh my
gosh is he gonna try my queen don't trap
my queen
don't do it okay he didn't do it that's
good
I was watching Chile's stream and his
goal is 2,000 by the end of the month so
I have to beat him
that's really the only goal
guy or game losing streak while at least
I saw streak
I don't think they give you points for
that still down the pong Nathan with a
host Thank You Nathan
preciate that's so generous
Nathan gifting subs making Clips
throwing bits apologizing the great
person
let's not get secured and he was
threatening rook g3
so disappointed I was about to say let's
win this game to keep my perfect score
but my perfect score has vanished of
queen bee 3 okay some proof
you
so weird position play this
at least my rooks have semi-open files
you're gonna play h3h3 I can play this
you still wants to play Brooke g3 play
queen h5
and then move here
oh I forgot about that it's not the end
of the world just lose upon
survive
my king will be safe on on e7
I mean I don't deserve this because I
completely miss bishop take f6 but it's
turning out nice nice thinking
he's wondering why it's not like a
bigger advantage but I just want to play
this and this rooks attacked it spawn is
pressured
his night is terrible
hello handing lovable it's a new person
Thomas plays GN level
I don't know GM wouldn't be taking so
much sciences position
I have a decent score against him
do this
okay this Queens about to get trapped
I want to play reggae chains
he's gonna play he's debating whether to
put a piece on e3
looking at g6 but that runs into e5
enough to start with queen f2
I still want to play Rakesh AIDS
he's probably gonna flag which is nice
you
rook h8 he takes Bishop d4 he moves the
knight
[Music]
let's do this first wait no Queen Laos
Queen h4 check
what am I doing with my life Queen rook
8/8 tick-tick-tick g5
a little bit concerned here i'ma play
Queenie - it's another one of these like
tickling moves
oh he had a good mood that was a good
move
okay we have to go into some endgame
g6 I'm down to pawns for one part I
can't count one I'm down to pawns
it's defending this pawn
wait this is gonna be a tough position
to convert down so many pawns
you
Oh
one back
it's trying win another back
v6
take this
was kind of scary
he's playing on increments I want to
play f6 very soon
I was a good move he's tied down his
rook can't get into play let's kick his
knight I'm gonna win e5 or I not
how do I win this when there's
increments
five here for Bishop no bishops III
plunders split you five
and nights are so tricky
after windy - at some points
his night is kind of stuck do this
it's gonna be okay with a draw I'm not
okay with a draw I'm playing this for a
win I'm gonna play King d3 and win this
pawn
and he flags yes I didn't deserve that
but back to tournaments still in first
place a point ahead of on Achatz
counting is really hard especially when
there are so many pawns for both sides I
know I had like somewhere between like
four and eight pawns but it's difficult
to count
okay let's try and get my rating back to
the normal spots
was that a dirty flag can you dirty flag
someone when there's increment maybe
that was still kind of dirty I'm playing
Casper clown again
I who almost beat me last time let's
position him I will play e5
boo Kings gambit let's play
to actually play this line
it's a very ambitious line
ninety-two I haven't seen 92 before the
run into e3
midnight c4 hmm I don't have much time
to think
maybe Bishop this looks nice Bishop g4
what's going on here maybe this
should have some compensation for the
pond it's just weird
some point I'll win back d5
he plays g4 what does this move
Queen h4 is coming
Rock of Kings gambit is Queen h4 is a
constant worry for whites
he's gonna play Queenie one I have
Bishop h3
was looking nice is he gonna get mated
kingi one Bishop c5 it's not immediately
mate
it's about to be made
if he plays Queen off - I think I would
play e3
is that too cruel Queen up to III
nothing is too cruel in chess
hmm no I wanted to play e3 what is this
I'm losing again to this guy
okay at least I didn't spit out my
coffee
how do them
the worst luck
I was so excited to play III too
at least I have some carp here I'm about
to castle as king is still unsafe should
still be winning
I do this is no checks
yeah no yes 25 oh my gosh okay
this is really bad I miss queeny five
I'm Mouse slipped by wanting me five huh
um I have 33 seconds and no increments
this is really bad Lisa's rook is on
each one
if I was coming
this is such a terrible game
III was such a fun move to
you
I see five when this pawn
I'm threatening 9c2 as well let's take
the pawn
lady six kick the night
you
twenty-one seconds this is
not looking good I need a miracle like
what happened last game with this guy
kg5 is coming
maybe a five first
for
you
you
so bad
hon storm
and double up
going for the attack 16 seconds left
boo free pawn not mess up again
you
you can't attack my pawning in
making some progress
ten seconds left
that is why not
master of comebacks of
the goddess counterplay
counterplay
you
mmm as bad
ah that's really bad
am i doing
Hanz
you
that's not meat
you
you
I coming back
you
No I almost came back there please still
make me he's not gonna still make me oh
I was so close to that was really
unfortunate
I didn't play e3i Mouse lips I had
chances though
so disappointed I lost so many rating
points what was that mouth slip I wanted
to play III okay doctor tournaments
passed on our kids there's half hour
left
RIPD Blitz rating without a different
clip or the same clip
had chances I probably played some
inaccurate moves there
even towards the end like the the king
and rook versus King in two maybe there
is some chance to draw
rating points slide
I want to play this guy Tushar these we
just started a game
well okay I can't a flea buzzer commence
I was about to say I'm not gonna be zerk
but if they're below 1,400 after berserk
a scotch gambits in honor of ex villager
always asking about the scotch
this is transposing to a Ponzi honey
I'm not gaining any rating I clean this
game
oh he paused because he doesn't want to
play me
interesting
he's using some dirty tournment attics
well if I pass them then I'll have to
play me at some point to catch up
to nirvana Ramon's always joining at
some point
v5
[Music]
did I do here maybe rookie one looks
interesting oh he paused so he could to
play me
oh he wants to play me Oh interesting uh
do I take now I can play this move
and stuff is attacked
you
it's to cure maybe I'm not winning
anything
[Music]
ooh I really want to sack my sack
take-take-take check I think this works
takes here then I can take on e6
other work
you
mm what's going on here
to simplify
so I could have taken an e6
I still can
you
what does that move it's a good move I
live up upon because I can count
but what you do next
let's play this trade rooks please take
on a - that would be fun
okay this is also fun
okay time to convert a King pawn ending
that's nice
whenever you're down upon oh wait this
is scary
23
whenever you're down the pond and a rock
ending do not trade rooks the general
rule of advice
you
okay
well at least I won a game by buzzer
King I'm tied for first place
upon because I can count well the other
game I was down to pawns but I couldn't
counts I don't know what the material
situation was okay I'm playing my
arch-nemesis for this tournament its way
of London
have not lost to him who is c5
I know if you prepare this for me I play
this line a lot
he knows what he's doing but not really
usually he supposed to take in 99 f6
Bishop III and hold on to this pawn as
long as possible
maybe a three Thank You sugar plate we
95 there because now I'm I just want to
play d4 and be up upon
that was played before
tick
so I'm up upon I have increments forgot
to berserk it's probably a good thing
though
and take just trade everything I like my
bishops or centralised Knight f4 with
tempo I might just go for the like a
media King side attack the queen h5
start throwing pieces
called Dania welcome back from shopping
s equals perfect day yeah this is uh
this is probably the busiest streaming
day I've had in a while
h4 on move because I did I did an email
extreme before the tournament started I
was about to play queen g4 that that
would hang a rook
I can play this so I did the email
extreme I made three new emotes with
chess players and then doing this viewer
tournament and then at 2:00 p.m. there
is this like arena Kings tournament on
chess calm so I'm probably going to do
that and then after all of that I'm
going to take a run
so close to perfect day
rook t8
as my queen is tied down to my rook
what do I do
our cage 3 looks interesting
mmm let's play rock h3 wait my eight
pawns hanging
who cares about eight pawns I care about
rock lifting
okay wait a minute I'm smelling tactics
I think I can take this wait this is so
confusing
I'm gonna take first I'm going to take
here
in the rook and now there's stuff
happening all over the place
I know he's watching so I'm not gonna
say anymore I'm just gonna say this
stuff happening
cool guy you're welcome first time in a
long time that I've done a tournament
like this so if you guys enjoyed it I'll
do more
but it's still not over there's 21
minutes left the ice won a game
congratulations ice Nathan F going back
to work
Nathan F
hmm
okay
ooh he was scared of Bishop take h7 okay
well this is nice
because now why doesn't material oh I
didn't see that move though that's a
good move
I'm going to be down material
oh my gosh
missing a lot of things today
you
beef okay let's play this first
now it's gonna be queen night and for
aggresses queen night and for most
likely
but I'll have a pass fun
I'll also have an isolated pawn
I'm not sure which side is for choice
the goal is to win this position
okay this is gonna be an interesting
kind
kind of wanted more from the earlier
position but what to do
let's keep Queens on the board wait a
minute
take too many risks
yeah I have to trade
what's going on 395 is a problem it gets
too much activity okay I'll trade trade
I'll play c3
see what happens
my endings are deceivingly tricky
so step one is King activity
go for this
see if he wants to play our five
g6
you can play g4
you
now you play this f5 or I have to take
[Music]
this is looking very draw do this
to take
probably dries
but I still have hope
I really don't want to draw this game
he has 24 points I have to play for a
win is bad
uh let's play knight back to f4
throwing the check
and do this
he's playing well
push the pawn
keep pushing push them baby
you
okay that was a good move
play this
/ push this
as I'm making him think
you
that's all I need need to make him think
thinking
let's do this
boxing out the King now
you can play 96 but then I'll have extra
pond
keep thinking keep thinking
- I do now I'm thinking
you
hmm
going for the sign
okay this is getting weird
this is just a draw
you
good game that was tough
I need to come back somehow he got two
points for that game I need to berserk
and win the rest of the games Bishop a6
was a nice move there
it's very possible I might not win this
tournament
I tried that night ending
was tricky with the chest icon turned in
starts in six minutes
no it starts in they said 12 p.m.
Pacific time
please confirm that though as otherwise
I'll switch over
Oh cameras working
I'm tile MCN I am NOT a happy with
second place not at all happy
gonzo chess 75 please let me know
because III did schedule the chess lock
on tournament but I had scheduled for 2
p.m. Central Time
which starts which would be an hour in
five minutes from now
I have it right okay great 3:00 p.m.
Eastern that's what I thought
or playing this fun Budapest line this
is actually a very fun line
and hopefully he doesn't know anything
even if he does know something it's hard
to meet III
p3 is not the best move the Syrian nm
it's a new name hello and welcome ooh
that was a nice house a nice scheme
Syrian and then brought some good luck
there I got the buzzer 'king points like
it'll play to char again cuz he's pause
but all he wants to do is play me I
don't think it's going to Paris so be
unpause
allow him to play me twice in a row it
could be wrong though
time see ya
not content with anything other than
first place I'm close I just need
another game to start let's booze Erick
con London
they see for
hmm what does this efore before looks
nice
and I can take over I hung up on that he
didn't see it so weird start
good move
and get away with this I think I can
my goal is to someday get into d6
someday play d5 in 96
a bishop said it just makes the job
easier
not do it right away I want to play h5
or I want him to play h5
there's each six aha I want to go for a
night f4
I'm plans of night at 4:00 and 95 look
interesting
96 looks very interesting but what's the
right execution
I'll start with this
hey I'm singer 24 haven't seen you in a
while
still love you thanks for subbing
you
I'm singers the best but I'm not sure
what I like more I'm singer or my
Knights in this position the Knights are
so exciting
lays there improve
further I want to take on s7 and then
just rip apart everything
do I yell it I'm singer I don't remember
yelling at em singer
now I'm trying to remember
I wanna sacrifice anything well I have
20
I'll can have to sacrifice forgot about
time I'm singer gifting a sub
anam was nice of him
I keep forgetting this is this is
dangerous buzzer 'king in time control
it increment
and then I see my opponents rating and I
get waste way too relaxed
okay let's take on g7 move back
maybe I can trap this Queen just wanna
play a five and strapped is queen
that would be really nice
you
cael's rook lifts Ben rook lifting a lot
today
we'll play like Queen before I'll play
rook or not
okay Queen f4 is coming in still play
Queen a7
a 2007 is a pretty sad move
there's now I'm threatening this I'm
threatening this how is he going to
defend everything
you
probably 98 he saw the made threat
okay but this is completely winning I
just have to not flag
I'm still attacking everything
he's gonna play it's gonna give me more
stuff
a queen g3 is kind of scary have to be a
little bit careful
starik
oh good move
12 seconds left there should be enough
time
meet me
my threatening mate
you
oh you just hung his queen since giving
me everything okay eight seconds is
plenty of time
oops
five seconds is plenty of time
okay back to tournaments I made it to
first place on the kids still pause why
is that
no more coffee well seven minutes left
I'm on a streak now
aliquat lost his streak so things are
lookin rights
50 players in this tournament wow so
many people hello to everyone who's
playing I don't really do much to
publicize this tournament
because it was only last night I found
out I could schedule a tournament for
future dates so I scheduled this
tournaments about 12 hours ago playing
another raccoon the same raccoon by play
but before
five
it's a good move to play against a
person who priests moves t4
we have some kind of this is called
Blackmore Deemer
the playable opening
Mortimer
oh yeah if you're getting paired against
1400s I apologize for that
I guess those are the people who watch
me
you should age for
yeah and singer could have played the
great thing about this position is White
has open F file
and Black has almost nothing developed I
take
don't want to relieve crusher but I
think this is just very strong
trade everything queen h5
you
and then another rook lift so much
lifting my arms hurts a seven hangs
no lease thanks for subscribing I
haven't seen that name before
I appreciate that we're gonna have a lot
of new emotes on the way so all the
subscribers out there I will hopefully
provide some some value
be careful of my Jeep on
you
the equal material it is equal material
he's defending well
this play rock g4
the smooth
I want to just take on each six do this
first I don't think he could defend the
H pawn this is just unstoppable threat
because now it's made into I was nice
oh wow yeah he was defending well for a
point there you just had to be very
careful bishop g6 should not be played
only he should bring his rook in thing
oh that was berserk
good game berserk not that was berserk
so many animals bear raccoon okay well
my rating is still dead but I'm in first
place let's yeah let's brazier
ah what do I want to play they see five
pre-move g6
he's playing the London stick in b6
you
mm-hmm
and try and be aggressive
aggressive as possible
someday I'll go for a 5 someday she may
be next move
is if he takes AI of night age five
I can take back with pawn
I just want to open the center and
somehow attack now my queen has more
scope
for potential
tej three potential
I'm gonna play Knight C for my P plays
my c4 I'll probably take it
there's a lot of attackers on the pond
what to do do this
okay I have to watch my time I'm gonna
play quick stay focused
I want to let bring my rooks to the
center
some plan is like rook c8 and night b4
he's attacking upon's do this
I don't think you can attack upon
further
now I want to play rook to you then
Bishop Bishop f5
Michael Buntyn I don't know playing the
London against me is trying to bite jaws
mmm
jaws is by the bull
my winning material I'm winning material
this is what is he doing about this
you
he didn't see my threat or he didn't
hear my threat
maybe he's Helen Keller
this is nice she's gonna start thinking
I'm gonna win it at least a exchange
maybe more
Conte Gandhi three
and then this pawn is weak okay
yes some counterplay though
Queen b3
be safe like to do this and maybe this
in this
I have 30 seconds to win this game
before the term ends
whoo he has a really good move here
don't play it okay he could have taken
on that seven I think
that would have been
I don't know I've to analyze afterwards
he wants to draw I don't want to draw
decline
pre-move f3
is closed
now act 3
as it now is night as pinned I'm
threatening this
it's flaking g-seven first
oh I could have taken no I couldn't have
taken now I still can't take what is
going on
I'm better but my time is bad
I don't know if I met her
I trick him
I just hang material this is really bad
wait a minute this is really good
here at night c6
it's kind of scary no does your
perpetual
he doesn't to the play Queenie 7 what a
messy aim
[Music]
there's very low quality
okay time to convert
you
I can pre move that
no checks no good checks
is going to play queen g4 and then I'll
play Queen d4
you
or not okay good game well
that was a fun tournament
thank you everyone for playing battery
safe and sorry yeah I'm not sure why
ionic it paused she had very good
chances to win that tournament but good
performance the second place
yeah back to tournaments lot of players
thanks everyone for playing oh I didn't
want to go over that last game I was
against this guy
you
there was one moment
where was it
no this is the first game oh I play them
the first game and the last game
last game didn't count for the
tournaments
go to my profile
call us 13th lucky 13
was there a moment there is a moment in
this game I wanted to take a look at
well first of all okay he had knight c6
here
he's just winning exchange I think I'll
be down upon but going back even further
I don't know what I was thinking about
maybe that was just a normal position
next time make it unrated I think rating
adds some song it makes it a bit more
serious some people care about their
ratings I don't really care too much
about my rating I am disappointed that
I'm now so far away from 2400 but I'll
have to work my way back up
so I think what I'll do is I will end it
very soon I'm gonna go ahead and submit
emotes there's a lot of famous people
streaming I'm probably the least famous
person out of all of these people Fiona
the huge following
Andrew who nice who do i raid tell me
who to raid i raid Fiona do i raid
Andrew
need more viewers hundred thirty okay
I'm in the raid Fiona because she's just
getting back getting back into streaming
um I was watching her stream earlier I
kind of felt bad starting my own stream
while she was streaming well we're gonna
raid her so I want everyone to uh to
join her stream uh and I'll type in the
raid command you know Jetta
Chetta and I'll be back later I'll be
back in in 45 minutes about for a chest
icon tournaments I think it's a bullet
tournament I don't know too much about
it but I'll be back very soon a rating
phenom Chetta and goodbye everyone